las familias Se reencuentran tras años
de estrictas restricciones mientras se
acerca el año nuevo chino es el caso de
Ciudadana de Singapur que visita a su
familia en Shanghai Después de tres años
sin poder ingresar en el país el 8 de
enero el gobierno chino puso fin a las
últimas reglas de su política cero covid
y reabrió sus fronteras permitiendo a la
gente ingresar sin necesidad de
cuarentena
por fin pude volver llevo mucho tiempo
esperando este día
Aunque el billete es muy caro pero
también se acerca el año nuevo lunar Así
que podré pasar las vacaciones con mi
familia sin embargo los casos de
contagio aumentaron drásticamente en las
últimas semanas según Grecia en estudio
de la Universidad de Beijing hasta el 11
de enero el 64% de la población se había
contagiado con el virus después de que
el país relajara abruptamente sus
restricciones tras una oleada de
protestas A mediados de diciembre según
el ex jefe de epidemiólogos del centro
de control de enfermedades de China el
pico de casos continuará hasta febrero y
marzo y el gigante asiático podría
reenponer pruebas a Los viajeros
Aunque la patogenesidad del ómicron
puede haber disminuido en cierta medida
su transmisibilidad ha aumentado por lo
tanto exigimos a Los viajeros entrantes
que se sometan a una prueba de ácido
nucleico en las 48 horas previas a la
salida según las cifras oficiales china
solo registró unas decenas de
fallecimientos recientes por Kobe 19
pero la OMS acusa de Beijing de falta de
transparencia en los datos que comparte
con la comunidad internacional algo que
Beijing niega china solo ha reportado
unas 5000 muertes desde el inicio de la
pandemia algo que sería una de las tasas
más bajas del mundo en un país de 1400
millones de personas